might I had a wonderful relationship but
we didn't always agree on everything and
one of the things that we had a
conversation about was her being in one
of these Tyler Perry madea movies and my
had always stayed on me to be careful
about my choices and to make sure that I
was doing work that mattered and then I
wouldn't connect myself to projects that
you know didn't deserve my participation
for whatever the reason might be so we
have these conversations all time about
valuing she would never put it this way
but about respecting my brand and
valuing my brand and so when I heard and
learned that she was going to be in one
of these madea movies we had a chat
about it one day and I want to know why
she would agree to beat and one of these
Madea films the short end of the story
is that she made a distinction for me
that I never really thought about there
is some very beautiful and brilliant
powerful high art that we should not
deny ourselves and there is some
run-of-the-mill entertainment that makes
us feel good that makes us laugh that
brings us joy that we should not deny
ourselves and she acknowledged the tyler
perry movie wasn't high art it was
entertainment but should I deny myself
an opportunity to be in a film where I
can speak to a generation of young
people and share a poem as a grandmother
in this in this film that might help
some of these young people even though
it's coming through an entertainment
vehicle in a movie with Medea in it I
should not do that but it became a
serious conversation that again that
allowed me to see this critical
distinction between what I view this art
and what I viewed as entertainment that
conundrum that dilemma came full circle
for me after she passed away when I had
to make a decision about whether or not
to appear on Dancing with the Stars and
I found myself in the same space art
versus entertainment ultimately I
decided to do Dancing with the Stars and
I could kind of hear my in the back of
my head saying okay you get it now I
feel sometimes for those in the broader
hip-hop community who seem to bear the
brunt of every critique in every
criticism that people feel comfortable
leveling at it hip-hop music is like any
other form of music or any other
of entertainment um there's some good
and there's some bad and when people
paint hip hop whether it's ben Carson of
my friend Geraldo Rivera with a painting
hip hop with a broad brush they get
themselves in trouble it's about
respecting people's individuality and if
you want to talk about a particular
person or a particular song then that's
had that conversation but you cannot
love everybody into one broad category
and demonize the entire art form